josh rogers kind of a control and
command guy knows
how to pitch to contact he mixes speeds
he locates well so expect him to throw
strikes here's alonzo three for eight in
this series he's driven in three runs in
the first two games they are at first
and nobody out 02 to alonso
lift it out toward right center field
back goes thomas deep in the gap and
it's off the wall
vr racing for third he'll be stopped
there alonzo pulls in at second base
with an opposite field double 20th
double of the year for alonso and the
mets are in business second and third
nobody out
and he hits one the other way that's a
base hit vr comes in with the first run
alonso will go to third michael conforto
with an rbi single and three batters
into this game the mets have the lead
it's one nothing new york high slider
stays back goes with it there's tyler
mcgill only gave up uh two runs on one
hit folks last time out against
washington that 9-4 when he got the win
elaine thomas
thomas the center
backing up pilar on to the track at the
wall
lane thomas has done it again
second home run as a national this guy
will not stop producing offensively
fastball up you're gonna roll the rest
loud noises see you later the first and
third one outs for carter kibu
there it is keep him through the right
side
metz had the shift on kibum takes what
they give him
rbi single makes it 2-1 nets
rbi number 17 on the airline move and
same seats right now in the first enemy
here we go
clean route to that ball as well
first pitch swinging is james mccann
this one way up in the air on the left
side andrew stevenson is going to take
charge i like how everybody bailed out
there you know why because you can see
players
out of your peripheral vision so even if
i'm calling it and i say i got it i got
it i got it and they say take it take it
take it luis garcia
pop foul davis hoping and sliding and
he's got it as he flips over the tarp
wow jd davis
outstanding play by jd contended with
the oncoming tarp and won the battle 2-2
swing and a miss strike three that ball
tipped into the glove of mccann as tyler
mcgill gets his first strikeout
punches out the opposing pitcher there's
two up two down in the bottom of the
second lane thomas who led off the first
inning with a home run
thomas strikes out to end the inning so
a better inning for mcgill as he sets
him down one two three with a couple of
k's alonzo off the second jd davis takes
his lead from first
serves it to the right side josh bell is
there he's going to take it himself nice
and beat
got pretty good speed for a guy his size
josh bell showed it off there
and helps josh rogers put up a zero in
the top of the third go to the bottom of
the third inning at nationals park and
the mets trail the gnats two to one of
the cities escobar
and he tries to hold but he went around
strike three
so escobar strikes out in a fastball
away that's three consecutive strikeouts
now for mcgill two away in the third
inning
and mcgill strikes him out with a
fastball
so tyler mcgill with his fourth
strikeout he's now set down eight in a
row two to one nationals go to the top
of the fourth inning
this is a change-up that's driven out to
left-center stevenson back
and a nice lunging catch as he got close
to the wall a little fist pump from
rogers stevenson moving back on that
ball well for out number one pretty good
swing by jeff mcneil gave it a ride
andrew stevenson knew where he was at
reaches up makes the play a little body
language because that's what
josh rogers does carter kibum singled to
right drove in a run back in the first
and he caught the outside corner kibum
can't believe it
bill wilkie punches him out and that's
five strikeouts on the last six batters
for tylor mcgill
stevenson firm ground ball up the middle
for a base hit had two knocks coming off
the bench in the first game of the
doubleheader it's now one for two in
game number two
and he hits a double play ball vr to
guillerme and onto first six four three
double play side retired rogers at
66 pitches 43 for strike he brings the
leg up and the arm around and he struck
him out swinging with a fastball at 89.
do it josh rogers with a little pizzazz
yeah spun off the mound
and good stuff breaks out the changeup
back-to-back strikeouts for josh rogers
here in the fifth
garcia left center this ball's got some
carry
back on it as mcneal will play it off
the wall
luis garcia again
with the double his fifth two bagger of
the home stand and then that's half
their lead off man in scoring position
here in the fifth
rogers now trying to move garcia to
third
rogers will push the bunt that way and
that's perfect
davis has to vacate
the bag throws a cross
for the first down here in the fifth and
josh rogers is doing a little bit of
everything here tonight so it falls to
el cidies escobar
smokes one to center
back on it is pilar onto the track at
the wall
it's gone
alcides escobar picks lane thomas up and
brings himself into
two run shot
the nationals are up 4-1 here in the
fifth
second home run is the national for
lcd's escobar and that's a big one
leadoff man on here in the sixth of this
seventh inning game and one out and one
on kevin pillar coming up
rocket to deep left field back goes
stevenson near the wall and it's out of
here
kevin pillar strikes for a two-run homer
to get the mets back within a run he's
had great swings all night
he's been on rogers pitches
and he finally got one to hammer his
13th home run of the year to cut the
net's lead to 4-3 tyler mcgill back to
the match for the bottom of the sixth
facing josh bell
and he chases the change up for strike
three so mcgill picks up his seventh
strikeout
one out on the bottom of the sixth three
two coming to key boom
there strike three 96 on the outer edge
from tylor mcgill
carter kibum's just been ejected
ejected from the game after arguing the
third strike call
gonna be a big boy save here for kyle
finnegan
baez with two for five in the opener
today
got him perfect execution by kyle
finnegan and riley adams that's what
we're talking about right it started to
strike out of his hands it broke off the
plate into the dirt i pitch walk to vr
and that brings up pete alonso
representing the go ahead run vr takes
off adam's the throw down
jonathan vr's 11th stolen base of the
season has him in scoring position pr
off second the 1-2 to alonso
in there strike three call
kyle finnegan with two strikeouts in the
seven and the nationals have snapped
their seven-game losing streak and
beaten the mets here in game two of the
doubleheader